to your question what should we be doing
well what i think we should be doing is
again going back to the big picture we
should be trying to split the russian
chinese alliance okay so we don't have
to contend with this warring block
and what we should do is uh i think we
should be raising the readiness level of
our strategic nuclear forces right now
biden has basically broken precedent
back on i think it was february 27th
that putin put his forces on high alert
his nuclear forces have been high alert
they've been ready for a nuclear war
they've been threatening nuclear war
every day and we haven't responded you
know in the past when the russians did
something like that we would raise the
defcon level that's the readiness level
the lowest level is five you know the uh
and and our forces are
at readiness five right now that makes
us vulnerable to a nuclear pearl harbor
the the bombers are not are you know
could be destroyed on their bases the
most of our ballistic missile submarines
are still in port they could be
destroyed in their bases with just two
warheads you know the icbms are the only
thing that would be ready we've only got
400
icbm warheads you know against an
enormous target set in russia and
they've got hypersonic weapons that
could perhaps you know
destroy those icbms before they could
launch
uh
so uh you know what we should do is
raise the defcon level
at least to defcon 3 so that our forces
are in a more survivable posture so that
the russians would be less capable of
doing a nuclear pearl harbor and then
immediately communicate to moscow that
look at we're raising our our forces to
defcon 3 because you guys increased the
alert of your forces and you have left
us no choice we don't plan to attack you
this isn't a plan for a surprise nuclear
attack we want peace
so
let's both sides lower the readiness of
our nuclear forces back to a normal
level and while we're doing that let's
have an immediate cease fire in ukraine
and let's go to the negotiating table
and negotiate a piece based on the peace
treaty that you offered that you moscow
offered to nato and the united states
before you invaded ukraine that peace
treaty the biden administration didn't
even seriously try to negotiate it
there were many points of that treaty
that should have been acceptable to us
not least not having ukraine and nato
and promising not to expand nato further
east it's even more in our interest than
it is russia's interest to not expand
nato even further further to the east so
there are many points in that treaty
that should be acceptable to us the
point of this process is that this could
be a golden opportunity okay to turn
lemons into lemonade and to hit the
reset button with russia do you think he
would entertain that
i think he would uh i think he would
because uh because in the long run
uh because first i don't think putin's
crazy i don't think he's in a sick bed i
think that putin
had wanted to realign himself with the
west during the trump administration i
think that he sees china as the bigger
long-term threat to us than the west
i think that if he could return to
normalcy certainly his oligarchs would
like it as and you know as you uh
uh pointed out
uh you know so i think that there is a a
significant possibility you know that uh
that we could use this uh and the most
important thing
immediate thing from my point of view is
though the one vital national interest
we have in the ukraine war
is to stop it because of the nuclear
escalatory possibilities this idea that
we can control our involvement in
ukraine and that nothing is going to go
wrong that things are not going to go
off the tracks and and turn into a
nuclear into a nuclear war by accident
or miscalculation is really
unwise frankly
a historical i mean just think of how
world war one started you know a single
bullet fired by a serbian terrorist in
the chest of a archduke
blew up into a nuclear war very excuse
me into world war one very quickly uh
you know that killed millions of people
uh ukraine is far more important
strategically than serbia was and the
and the possibilities for escalation
there are enormous we need to get out of
this situation uh you know desperately
uh to avoid this this escalate these
escalatory possibilities so there are
two huge u.s national security interests
that would be solved here
uh uh terminating the ukraine war so the
escalatory possibilities are ended and
splitting
the uh the russian uh chinese alliance
so that we have some kind of a chance to
win the new cold war against china i
think i think
putin could be persuaded to become a
neutral at least a neutral but maybe
even a strategic partner through the
process of negotiating and resolving our
conflicting security views
you know i don't think you're going to
be able to
i think it's too much to hope that
russia is going to be contained forever
and they're not going to want to have
their empire back you know that's what
bolton was talking about about the 30 to
100 year war i think bolton is right i
think the russian people not just putin
they want their empire back they want
great russia back and they're going to
fight for 30 to 100 years
diplomatically and militarily if
necessary to do that do we have the
political will to oppose that for thirty
to one i don't think so we don't didn't
even have the political will to defeat
the taliban so let's be realistic about
our foreign policy we're not the global
you know we're not we're not able to
control the whole world and we're not
responsible for controlling the whole
world we're chiefly responsible
to the american people to protecting our
lives protecting this country and
protecting our civilization and this is
as i can see it is the is the as the
quickest way
and safest way to uh to end the ukraine
war and to position ourselves to to to
win the new cold war by by achieving the
most important objective right now which
would be should be to split the russia
china alliance so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]